こんにちは！こちら スティーヴ コーフマン です
今日は…　まあ普通はね、言葉の勉強について話をするわけですけれども
今日はね、言葉及び英語を
勉強しないことに、
どうして勉強をしない方がいいか、と
それについて話したいと思います。
僕のビテオ好きであればぜひサブスクライブ（登録）してください
鐘の所をクリックすれば通知が届きます
はい　　どうして英語の勉強をやめたほうがいいか、と
あのー　僕の場合はね、日本語勉強する前は中国語を勉強したわけですよ
で　どうしてもその　「勉強」　という二つの漢字を見るとですね、
どうしてもこの…　「勉强 (miǎn qiǎng)」　という中国語の単語を思い出すわけですよ
で　「勉强」　というのは
もう強いて　やりたくないことをやる、ということです
「勉強」
嫌だ、嫌でやる、というものは
中国語の「勉強」の意味なんですよ
で、
言葉の…
やはり、言葉を習うというのは、
実際の脳の動き方を見るとですね、
その好きでは無いものを引いて、
嫌でも習うというのは非常に非効果、効果が低いんです
効果が低い。
だから　あのー　学校やめて
正式な「勉強」もやめて、
楽しいことをやらないといけないです
それについてちょっと今日は　話するつもりなんです
このためにもLingQという言葉のウェブサイトを作った訳ですよ
LingQで好きなものを選んで、
好きな内容から勉強する
でその「勉強」、また「勉強」ですけど、
習う方法というのは、
聞いて　読んで
自分が面白い、好き、と思うような
物を聞いたり、読んだり
することだけで、やはり
その言葉が頭に入ります
そして、
LingQの図書館のある、レッスンの内容が面白くないならば
またどこからでもLingQに導入して、
使えることがあるわけですよ　だから　とにかく、
楽しく、楽しい内容から勉強することが大事なんですよ
いろんな仕方があるんですよ　例えば、子供
お父さん、あるいはお母さんがですね、
子供のためにストーリーを読むでしょ
しかし、もし声が
もしお父さん、お母さんがつまらないと思ってる話、
好きじゃないならば
赤ちゃんもそれを感じるわけですよ
そして、そんな
この…　新しい
単語や音を、ですね
なかなか頭の中にね、　定着されないんですよ
それは実際にあった実験なんですよ
それよりも、　やはり、子供に言葉を
発見させるためには
お父さんやお母さんがですね　自分が面白いと思う話、内容を
積極的に、楽しく話した方が　いいです
赤ちゃんはいずれ、　ちっちゃい赤ちゃん　まだ何も分からないから、
音だけ、　言葉そのものを吸収する立場ですから
だから読む人が、　お父さんお母さんがね、
自分が面白いと思う内容を
赤ちゃんの為に読みあげたほうが　効果的らしいんですよ
そして学校ではですね、やはり、
あのー先生がね、それじゃ　先生が積極的で
その　英語なら英語、が好きであれば、
それならいいんですよ
しかし、
先生がそうじゃ無ければ、
非常に　非効果ですよ
その同じクラスで勉強しようと思えば
えー　もう一つはですね　先生が
下手すると、「ルール」を教えるわけですよ
しかし、脳がね、ルールを、
ああいう形で勉強するのは難しい
脳はね、自分で「ルール」を作るわけですよ
刺激すれば　楽しい、面白い、
そのインプットがあれば、
あのー　最初聞いたら、あまり印象が無い
脳はね、一つ一つの細かい
えー　単語なら単語、　覚えるのは難しい
だけども、　たくさんたくさん
一つずつ色んな違った文章で、
単語が出てきたり、忘れたり、また出てきてぶつかったり、
するとですね、　頭が自分で「ルール」を作るんですよ
脳というのはそういう物なんですよ
いつも覚えてます　いつも「ルール」を作ってます
だから十分な刺激を与えないといけません
けれども、　その刺激は
脳にとって面白い、脳にとって楽しい、
でないと、なかなか（脳に）入らない　それが大事なんですよ
だから楽しくっというのは　大切
で「ルール (文法など)」はそんなに教えたくてもいい
例えば、また赤ちゃんの話ですけれども
赤ちゃんは走ることを習うわけでしょ
しかし、
考えてみれば、赤ちゃんにとって　歩くのはとっても難しいわけですよ
バランスを取ったり、自分の筋肉をどういう風に
力を入れたりするのか　とかですね
すごく複雑ですよ　で、最初は出来ない
だけども、少しずつ 少しずつ
一つ一つの努力や経験が記憶に残らないんですよ　赤ちゃんの
ただ、
全般的ないくつかの「ルール」を知って
こういう風に動けば歩くことが出来る、と
自分で、頭が作るわけですよ　「ルール」を　脳が
だから別に　「歩くのはこうですよ」って
「足はこうだ」とか　教えなくていいし
教えても無理
赤ちゃんの脳は、その「ルール」は自分で作る
言葉の覚え方も同じなんですよ
まず　自分の母国語を話すことから始めてね
そして外国語でも　たくさんの刺激があれば、
やはり　頭がいくつか「ルール」を、
最初は間違った「ルール」を作るんですよ　赤ちゃんも
赤ちゃんの脳が「ルール」を一生懸命作ろうとする
しかし　例えば英語の場合ではですね、
「think」。
色んな動詞で　～ed が、　例えば　「walk」➞「walked」
それで　「think」は「thinked」と言うかもしれません
少しずつ　「じゃあ　そのルールは上手く行かないから」で　「think」は「thought」って分かります
だから「ルール」は必ずしも正確じゃなくてもいいから
少しずつ 少しずつ
あのー　変化があって、
もっともっと正しい「パターン」が出てくるわけです
もちろん文法のルール　読んでもいいんですよ
読んで　もしすでに十分、たくさんな経験があるなら
自分が思った「ルール」で　「いや、そうじゃない　こうだ」と
いうような程度で「ルール」を見てもいいけど、　忘れる
しかし　覚えても忘れたり
脳が自動的に「ルール」を拵えて　その中から、
ますます正しい表現の仕方が出てくるわけですよ
発音もそうですね　発音も好きな声で
楽しい声で
僕が中国語を勉強した時に
「相声」という　お互いに笑い話をやってる人たちの
カセットテープをたくさん聴いた　楽しいから
楽しいから非常に　発音するにも役に立ちました
そういう意味ではですね
普通の教科書　それは英語であろうが日本語であろうが、　韓国語　中国語　…　皆
つまらない声、つまらないナレーターが
あのー　録音するわけでしょ
それは無意味　それよりも自分が好きな声
好きな内容　それを真似すれば、発音も良くなる
だから、　「勉強」というのはね
「勉强」という勉強はやめて　楽しく習いましょう
でそういう意味で　僕のビデオも
僕は自分の言葉の勉強のテーマは大好きだから
いつも　好きだから
自分が好きだっということが多分
私のそういう話の中でも現れていると思うんですよ
だから皆さんそれぞれの英語の勉強に役に立つと思う
だから僕のユーチューブチャンネルでも好きな動画、　英語のビデオ
ぜひ聴いてください
そして　場によってはそれを
大体LingQの英語の図書館にあるわけですから
YouTubeで観てもいいし
LingQに導入してもいいし　あるいはその図書館で検索してもいいけれども
ぜひ推薦します
じゃ、楽しく勉強　まあ「勉強」じゃない
楽しく覚えましょう　ということでね
はい　どうも　さよなら～